عندما ننتقل الى مكان جديد او نقضي بعض
الوقت مع صديق لديه لهجه مميزه غالبا ما
تتسلل الينا اللهجه تدريجيا دون ان نلاحظ
ذلك دراسه حديثه اجراها باحثه جامعه
بنسلفانيا كشفت كيفيه انتشار لهجات بين
الاشخاص مثل العدوى دراسه كشفت عن ظاهره
تعرف بالتقارب الصوتي والتي تحدث عندما
يبدا الناس في تقليدي نطق الاخرين عند
التحدث الى اشخاص بلهجه مختلفه الدراسه
خلصت لان اللهجات المختلفه تنتشر مثل
العدوى من خلال الاختلاط وترتبط بدرجه
الانخراط في المهام والعمل فكل ما كان
الفرد اكثر الانخراطا فيما يفعله مع
الاخرين كان اكثر عرضه التقاط لهجاتهم
وبالنسبه للهجات العربيه
اللهجه الجزائريه هي اصعب
اللهجات العربيه تليها تفاجئتوني فيها
المغربيه الليبيه فيما تعتبر اللهجه
المصريه اسهل واكثر اللهجات العربيه
انتشارا في العالم جميله لميس ابراهيم
اجرى تجربه هنا في العربيه حيث تتقارب
اللهجات وتنصهر كلها في لغتنا العربيه
الواحده
[موسيقى]
اختلاف اللهجات العربيه في العالم العربي
واقع مفروض ونحن جمعناها لكم تحت سقف واحد
في قناه العربيه فلنتعرف على اي هذه
اللهجات اصعب العراقيه انا تونسي
انا تونسيه وفلسطينيه انا من الاردن
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
انا تونسيه وفلسطين ورح اقرا مثل باللهجه
العراقيه الي ما يعرف يرقص
عوجه
يعني بس يعني يمكن نعرف نقولها ونقول
الكهرباء
[موسيقى]
كاشير
[تصفيق]
في الاستديو تنضم الينا صناعه المحتوى مها
جعفر مها ازيك يا مها
طيب ما هل فعلا قال لهجات تنتشر مثل
العدوى بين الاشخاص
العدوى الفتاكه بس شو السر فيها ليش بعض
الناس تكون لديهم ثلاثه اكبر في التقاط
اللهجه من غيرهم
بصراحه يعني بعتمد على البيئه اللي انت
عايشه فيها يعني لو انت عايشه اختلاف يعني
سلطه وفيها لهجات كتير فمخك بيكون يعني
بسبب اللهجات اسرع طلقات اللهجات اكثر طيب
مها انت من وين انا سودانيه تمام بابا
سوداني وماما عراقيه ومولوده في الامارات
[ضحك]
لا هو طبعا مصري يعني احنا كنا بنعرف
نتكلم مصري يعني اللهجه المصريه هي الاكثر
انتشارا في الوطن العربي طيب شو اللي يخلي
لهجه تكون اسهل من غيرها انت شاطره في
اللهجات الاعلام لان نحن كلنا متعودين على
الاعلام المصري للمسلسلات الافلام
فعشان كده الهدوم وكلنا بنفهمها بس لو
كانت يعني مثلا يعني هي اللهجه المصريه
صعب وفي كلمات صعبه على فكره يعني غير
الكلمات اللي احنا متعودين عليها بس لانه
متعودين من زمان ما بنشوفها سهله طبلنا
نتحدث عن مصر في مصر حيث اشهر الهجاء
عربيه سال الناس ما احب لهجه عربيه
بالنسبه لك وما اسهل لهجه عربيه بالنسبه
لك ايضا غير المصريه طبعا
[موسيقى]
احب اللهجه المصريه وبس الخليجي الاردن
العراق سوريا كلهم حلوين
في كمان اللهجه السوريه اللهجه السوريه
[موسيقى]
هم بيحبوا المصريين قوي
طيب مها دمك تحكي
طلاقه اكثر من لهجات شو اللي يميز في
كلهجه في جمله شهيره كده عباره شهيره تميز
احنا في جزائري بالزاف بحبك بالزاف وناكل
بالزاف وشريت بالزاف شوفي الفلهجات
الثانيه
يعني صراحه كلها يعني انا بالنسبه لي انا
بحب اللهجه احلى من الثانيه
[ضحك]
طبعا هالفتره لانه عم بتفرج على الثلاثه
كثير صاير احكي سوري سوري هيك بتحسيها هيك
كثير رايقه تمام شو كمان طبعا سوداني
المفضله لانه طبعا احنا
يعني لازم تحضري عندي مسلسل في اليوتيوب
اسمه ست النفر طبعا المفروض من زمان ما
نزلتها ست النثر لكن طبعا هنا هتشوفي هذه
السودانيه الحقيقيه
يعني
نرقص اماراتي مثلا مثلا
هلا فيكم شو اخباركم
يعني انا وايد احب الرسماراتي طبعا بحب
كلمه ارمس بحب اقوله بكل هسه
طيب نهى شو الي خلاك تتقنين ها اللهجات
شوفي المسلسلات شو في افلام الشعوب
اول حاجه لانه يعني انا اصلا عائله مختلطه
يعني العراقي والسوداني بالنسبه لي كانه
لغه الام همم ومولوده في الامارات احنا في
الامارات عندنا يعني
طول ما انا في المدرسه بشوف ناس من
جنسياتهم حتى المدرسين همم المسلسلات
الافلام
[موسيقى]